it's very difficult to be the same on
the pictures you are off it because
obviously when you have to pitch you
want to be de you know you want to be
nice and polite and if you everyone with
respect and you know be known for being
a good person but when you're on the
pitch you want to win so you sort of
lose track all the things that just
focus on winning and trying to be the
best player so when I first started
playing football I think I was about
five or six maybe really young lease
perv older guys in a car park outside
the front of my house and no one Keynes
and I fell in love with it straightaway
we used to used to other big trees as
the goalposts so you know it's quite a
big goal it was easier to score then
yeah I fell in love with a straightaway
and I think it helped my game a lot
because I was it when I was 16 I started
playing first in football for Milton
Keynes and I was already sort of adapted
my game to play against older people
I think street football shaped I am a
lot because it was a lot about
manipulating the other player and you
know trying to create your own space and
working in tight areas so I think when
you move that into an eleven decide game
obviously you can't play exactly the
same way but I feel like it helped me a
lot because when I find myself in them
situations I'm a lot more creative to
get out of them
I think the bit the fans don't see about
the dedication is uh see when you're
younger from the ages of eight to some
kids and you know even younger you're in
getting into Academy football you're
traveling all around the country there's
a lot of ups and downs from an early age
getting released for some players and
different things like that or even
having a bad game and it feeling like
the end of it's the end of the world or
not starting and having to overcome all
these different challenges that maybe
don't seem that serious but when you
know you can working towards something
the whole life these little things can
have a big effect on you and you have to
at the right mentality and keep working
hard and you know focusing and trying to
become the best player you can possibly
be you have to be a 24-hour professional
and be dedicated from such an early age
from even from when you're in school
trying to find the right balance and you
know understanding what's right and
wrong and how you have to approach every
different situation and you know as you
get a little bit older when your friends
want to do something they want to go out
and party you can't go put it off so you
have to have an early night because you
have to gain the next day and you have
to be at the right level to compete and
be the best player on the day so the
world today and how it is is with all
the social media all the TV pundits and
things like that everyone has an
opportunity to to have a say in an
opinion on the way you play which i
think is a great thing you know if
you're focusing on one of wanting to be
the best player you can be and trying to
achieve as much as you can and you know
having trust in the right people then
it's easy to to block that sort of
negatives out you don't if it will do
the talking
yeah there's a lot of people have to
thankful where I am now and teach you
from MK Dons I think he was massive
influence on me he had me at you know
what I felt was a crucial point in my
career I thought from 12 to 16 they can
go a lot of different ways but he helped
me through a lot in the coaching sense
and a lot as well as a person as a kid
helped me to mature and you know when I
went to the first team of coral Vinson
and even miked up as well so all the
coach just had an M case until 12 to 18
when I left they all helped me in
different ways and then for Chitina as
well since they're coming to Tottenham
put a lot of trust into me helped me to
to keep that hunger I always had and to
keep him running to him for
my advice is to enjoy playing football
not to worry about what anyone says and
don't beat yourself up if you're not
doing well at any age because sometimes
the failures you don't want to fail but
it's the best props we need to improve
yourself as a person and as a player so
don't worry things ain't going well and
keep working hard
[Music]
you